hi i'm sal khan founder of the khan
academy and as you might know we are a
not-for-profit organization with the
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and the
way that we're able to do that is
through the support of folks like you
khan academy is much more than me we're
over a hundred people developing the
math the science the humanities content
that you've
used and that people that you care about
have used the sat prep
the team that's building out the
adaptive software and allowing our
content and our software to be localized
around the world none of that will be
possible without your generous donations
so if you or anyone that you've cared
about has benefited from this i i
encourage you or i ask that you go to
khan academy.org and you think about
making a donation of any size any size
will help and what's especially exciting
is that is that between now and december
31st every dollar you donate will be
matched dollar for dollar up to 2.3
million dollars and so there's a great
way to get a huge return on your
donation so with that thank you for
using khan academy thank you for
supporting khan academy and i hope you
have a wonderful holidays